so what we're looking at is what's
called the Plan B's all a group now it's
important to recognize this is a plan
view of errors not the player view of a
house because usually a roof is what we
call Eve does anyone do what Eve's
are yeah there's it's a hangover so in
fact if you just have a look across at a
block right now like a tube 187 can you
see that the roof over there right now
guys it hangs quite far part the actual
route is done like we done maybe people
okay so you can see that the size of the
roof matters more than the size of the
actual group inside because the whole
words will collect water and if the
route but going to really far out battle
will collect water as well even if
there's no house underneath it it's how
much rooted okay you have a question
I'll let you answer that question
because I already have accident should
be picture okay good
think that and if you go down below also
don't in trouble now I
you got the sides of the roof with all
this dimensions so if you have a think
about this without actually worrying
about like how flyovers goes it is
really just a complicated question is it
so this is why I prefer to study this is
stuff we're going back in a before but
now we're applying for security so the
first thing to do is work out the area
of these positive roots now I will point
out generally the Rezai Graham will show
you these like lion tear that shows that
sort of record stuff going up spots and
angles of the root because it's not
really completely flat doesn't matter
how high up the ruse goes by gimmick
like this or if it's like this does that
make a difference
yeah yeah have to eat like okay stop
talking
put examine Pelham ah okay now here's
the thing right if rain is falling down
exactly vertically which one I know it's
not always okay but often it is if it's
fully not exactly vertically that if
you've got a ceiling a rich brother
feeling by the way if you're not sure
ceiling is the inside this is the
outside okay if you've got a roof like
this right versus a roof that has the
same area so like this width down the
bottom is the same but it's only like it
really showers or it could even be flat
okay there won't be a difference between
how much rain gets collected by that the
only difference is how quickly does the
water actually run down this route so
therefore you don't need any of the
other measurements just be area is
enough so can we work out how are you
going to calculate the area what would
you like to do call the chain yeah we
could cover done I'll be good so I think
probably an even way to cut up my
meeting saying that way not okay so if
you have a look at going or do like a
different kind of chain you
well let's have a look at this one's it
is time Maya left-handed Kegel I have
all the visuals on that back - Oy
do you agree yep what about the area
this dude over here now look carefully
this is the whole thing on that acres
all the way across
I had destroyed in myself so I'll go as
I think they which is yeah because five
and three they're together making H that
is a tire so therefore so I don't have
I'm actually not worried about any
triangles all of the here mark is
actually addition well you know he said
initialize to show you here is the roof
and it's like it angles up but I don't
care about the angle I'm just caring
about the kids in the bottom now I can't
you might be some down boy plug for slow
yes sure yeah Mon I calculated happy
thoughts okay so what does the area now
we want to combine it with these painted
in Michigan what's going on this is the
straightforward be rewarding to worry
about this how much rain is falling
somewhere multi bit by this okay that's
going to give me a volume of water
that's forward going to green but then
he mentioned this as well are we connect
now so the rain is falling on this it's
going to collect me closer by the
gutters and it hopefully funneled into
our rainwater tank okay but yeah baby
doll that's going to make it like like
some water or land and their children
splash off nice um I'm going to work out
a volume and then I'm going to remove
from that bigger cage that make it so
I'm gonna do that one time I'm gonna say
Colonel Rayne right this is before the
wastage okay now this is in beaches this
isn't millimeters so what would you like
me to do I'm not changed which one
should I change you want to change this
one in for no native okay if it good
reason to do that
what's the reason avoid decimals okay
there's also a bad reason to do it so
I'm not saying we shouldn't but if the
numbers become indulgences
right because how many meters very happy
millimeters are there in a video what is
nearly a millennium for example now it
needs analysis there are thousands of is
from end to end
so if there are a thousand elevated in
one meter I just ship it is like on the
other hand it's much as 1,000 this way
it's a square meter right so it's also a
thousand this way so how many square
millimeters on it it is square meter is
million right a thousand this way a
thousand is we're both so my numbers are
going to get three bit so let's try this
557 0 0 0 0 0
okay now I encourage you to include
those used a because I just got a
conversion I had it set it anywhere else
I'll join of it well that was the other
way in Robin converting this to meters
sorry disabilities is which is versus
submitted or we could convert both of
them to some other unit like they're
centimeters in between both I probably
could vote one thing rather treatment I
can't now 657 millions and someone got
it okay now its standard to say actually
it's a bit of a arm it's a bit of a hole
user and also we want to measure up
available like these which we know what
else I get to come we're going to talk
about water like bills and leaders it'll
likely be great
so can I convert these how many
buildings is that so actually this is
what I mentioned before right this is
actually quite a challenge to work out
because you've got to do more unit
conversions article let me rewind as it
is and go into a parallel universe where
I didn't convert it to an absorbent
number okay where it's better to very
near I could very good
so instead of six love image it's going
to be zero point what how many times up
here in your
all three calls to volume so sorry that
means now okay
now that multiply that by 57 meters
sweat unchanged that was not gonna be
here in time threefold now my question
to you is which of these because I have
the same just the difference of units
which is even easier to convert you
Mills leaders whatever I actually lead
to one before as well
you really can't do either but I think
my head starts to hurt when I look at
this okay so he now on the side if you
can't remember one mill they would vary
what bullying the bill picks up was
either picture okay
so if you don't very good at string of
volumes there may be different get like
a on the minutes a couple to another
collision performance at this size as
well this is the conversion okay it's
not very large so how do I convert this
is meter cube now what we're gonna do
so now that I realize truth is when I
need three so um here's my here's my
shipping sign squared a don't is much
right now but it also goes down this way
okay so each one of these lines is a big
decision should it be on is really big
right if it's this big it is fine and it
also comes out that far
scream masculine right so this is
actually going to be each cubic meter
each individual should agree now it's
going to be 100 centimeters by a hundred
failures by a lip service you're green
in other words is cubed so that's 1
million do you rescue guys that number
the one who is working out before it's
the same issue right so if you've got
achieve it meet us it's a million chin
accelerators so how many buildings are 1
million mils talk about that somewhat
useful unit one
if a thousand what later dated which is
one thing they're mentally absolutely
cigar did you pull it off nine yes some
of them school okay so I'm ready I'm
ready to actually see my conversion so
this is zero point three point three one
one can be beat up is one Q is 1 0
therefore younger appointment three four
DVD co-leader driving it and is there
anyone listening I can clearly point to
this it says I don't get all of that
right
that's uh that's a total ring okay so
now what I'm going to finish my thank
you so if I want to work out the rain
that was wasted with a gentle X IJ
attention to that okay if I go straight
through how much radio I actually
collect up on my right to do rain
collected
0.34 two cheerleaders if you want into
this what does it matter what is it you
can multiply by 90% of your life what
that is is definitely Iroquois not just
for that chemistry